It's likely that by now you've heard
about movie pass,
the subscription service that allows you
to see one movie per day in theaters for
$9,
95 a month,
except you can't see it will be more
than once.
You have to be a hundred yards from the
theater to book the ticket and during
certain times you have to pay a little
extra,
but despite all that movie pass is still
a pretty good deal.
In fact,
the deal might be too good for moving
past,
just as you've probably heard about
movie pass,
you've probably also heard the company
is losing money faster than a Tarantino.
Henchmen loses blood.
The problem is simple.
Movie past charges nine 95 a month,
and the average movie ticket and America
costs $9 and sixteen cents.
When you see a movie with movie pass,
they pay the full price of the ticket as
if they were buying a normal ticket for
a friend.
That means if you see just two movies a
month,
movie passes losing double what a gains
from you more.
If you're buying in a city where ticket
prices are more expensive,
multiply that by $3,
million friends and you can see why
movie pass is in a lot of trouble
financially according to the best
estimates.
The average movie pass subscriber sees
about one point five movies a month and
even though that's not three movies or
even to the numbers are still lopsided
and that point five of a movie is
bleeding them dry.
In 2017,
the company that owns movie pass,
Helios and Matheson lost a $150 million
dollars and in May the company revealed
in an sec filing that it's losing 21
point $7,000,000
per month on average at that time and at
that rate they only had enough cash
available to stay solvent for two more
months.
It's two months later now and well,
the website still works,
so that's a good sign.
If you're consistently losing money as a
business,
there's only one way to stay afloat by
finding investors to give you money in
the hope that some day you'll be
profitable in the future.
Investors investing in spotify or uber
or dropbox or blue apron,
all companies that have yet to become
profitable,
in fact of the 108 companies that went
public in 2017,
over three quarters weren't profitable.
Now not all unprofitable companies are
created equal.
Amazon was unprofitable for years,
but it had the revenue so it was just
putting them back into investments.
In the case of movie pass,
the revenue just isn't enough to pay for
the costs and movie past says it,
understands this.
It says it always knew it was going to
lose money on its path to acquiring more
subscribers and greater market share.
And to be fair,
the growth of the company has been
impressive.
Last August movie pass only had 20,000
subscribers when they lowered their
price to $10 a month,
almost a year later and they're
approaching $3 million with projections
of up to 5 million by the end of the
year.
The theory behind the price drop and the
reason they haven't yet raised it
substantially to stem their losses is
that it's supposed to attract the 51
percent of movie goers who only see
about three to six movies a year.
People who might pass on $20 or even $15
but can't resist 10 these people,
the theory goes,
we'll bring the average movie per
subscriber down,
but movie pass needs to look for cash
and other places to.
The original idea was that it could use
the app to track the movie going habits
of its users and sell that data to
studios for targeted advertising and to
restaurants nearby the theater who could
advertise to customers when they're in
the area.
Movie pass,
things that eventually if it can grow
enough,
it can negotiate a percentage of the new
business.
It's bringing two theaters and the
surrounding stores.
It thinks that it could potentially even
get a slice of a theaters only real
moneymaker concessions.
Let's see what the CEO of America's
largest theater chain has to say about
that.
Absolutely no intention,
no intention of sharing any of our
admissions revenue or concession.
Terrific Bitch.
Okay.
I added that last part.
It was good to get to it.
Sure.
There are a lot of forces at work in the
movie theater ecosystem and movie pass
is laying them all bear.
People are seeing fewer movies overall,
so theater chains have been raising
ticket prices and higher ticket prices
means people see fewer movies still and
don't take chances on what they do see
at theaters have it hard as it is.
Most ticket revenues get kicked back to
the studios who leveraged their power to
get even more percentage and now here
comes the subscription service,
the valuing the price of a ticket in the
minds of consumers asking for a cut of
concessions and yet movie pass is
bringing them business.
It's users are taking chances.
Again,
seeing movies on a whim.
it's bringing more people to the movies
more often.
It's just not bringing enough people.
Not yet.
The studios don't want to pay for the
data.
The theaters don't want to cut them in
and movie pass subscribers are just
seeing too many movies.
If there's a size at which this would
all change,
20 million subscribers maybe or 50
million or 100,
I don't know,
but it's a race now can move you past,
get to that critical size before it runs
completely out of money.
I guess we'll see.
Until then.
It is genuinely one of the best deals in
town.
Something I thought I'd never see a
bunch of rich investors taking millions
of people out to the movies.
Everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
skillshare and online learning community
for creators,
but more than 18,000
classes and everything from graphic
design to film editing,
finance it security.
You know,
when I learned photoshop,
I learned it through this mishmash of
disconnected youtube videos and I think
the process would have gone a lot faster
if there was a class dedicated to
teaching me everything about that
program in a systematic way.
Learning new skills is really valuable
to me because whenever I learn a new
skill,
it's like a bunch of new ideas are
suddenly unlocked in my head.
I think,
what can I do with this and that.
Always always helps me with writer's
block.
A premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses,
but the first 500 people to sign up
using the link in the description below
will get their first two months for
free,
and those two months you could easily
learn the skills you need to start a new
hobby or business.
More importantly,
the skills you learn will help give you
the ideas for what that business or our
project could be.
Definitely try it out.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.